let's get started and learn how to
convert percentages to decimals and if
we have time maybe we'll also learn how
to convert decimals into percentages so
let's get started with what I think is a
problem you probably already know how to
do if I said I have 50% 50% I don't know
if I wanted to write that thick but
we'll go with it actually let me change
it to a thinner one and I want to turn
that into a decimal well you probably
already have a sense of what decimal
represents 50% if I told you where we're
having a sale and it's 50% off you know
that's roughly half off or another way
with how do you say half as a decimal
well that's the same thing as point
let's say 0.5 so you might have known
that in your head but how would we is
there a system for being able to convert
this 50% to 0.5 well it turns out it's
pretty straightforward all you do is you
say whatever percentage it is that's the
same thing as the number over 100 right
and 50 over 100 is the same thing as 5
over 10 or 0.5 and even a simpler way of
converting percentage to decimals and
this I think you're going to realize
converting a percentage to a decimal or
the other way around you can pretty much
do in your head is if I say let's say 50
and I'm just going to add one decimal of
accuracy here just to show you a point
50 percent right if I want to convert
that 50 percent into a decimal all I do
is I get rid of the percent sign I'll do
it here 50 percent I get rid of the
percent sign and I take the decimal
point and I move it over two spaces to
the left so I say one two so this is
where the new decimal is so this equals
point we could say zero point five zero
zero so 50 percent is equal to zero
point five zero zero and of course these
last two zeros really don't
anything for our purposes so we'll get
rid of them so that's the same thing as
0.5 or just 0.5 50% equals 0.5 so you're
probably saying well sure that looks
easy but what if the problem gets a
little hard or 50% I've done in my head
so let's try some I would say slightly
harder problems if I were to tell you
that let's say sixteen point three two
percent well let's just do it the way I
just showed you we can get I'll rewrite
it down here sixteen point three three
two percent so if we get rid of the
percent sign scratch it out we just have
to move the decimal over two spaces to
the left so one two this is the new
place for the decimal that decimal goes
away
so it's point one six three two is equal
to sixteen point three two percent I
think you might be getting the idea now
let me do another one in green let's say
I had this one actually confuses a lot
of people let's say I had zero point two
five percent so the important thing to
remember is just let me know I'll be
right here zero point two five and maybe
I'll write zero zero point two and you
might probably wondering why I'm doing
this but I think you'll see in a second
why I wrote that leaving zero there
even though doesn't seem to add much to
it zero zero point two five percent well
just what's the system I just showed you
you get rid of the percent sign and you
move the decimal over one two spaces so
that equals point zero zero two five so
0.25 percent is equal to point zero zero
two five and you could put a leading
zero here
if you want some people it's actually I
should probably tell you to always do
that because it makes it easier to read
so 0.25 percent is equal to point zero
zero two five and I want to just
contrast that with 25 percent 25 percent
what do you think that equals well you
do the same thing that we've been doing
you get rid of the percent sign and you
move the decimal space in this case
actually let me leave that the I'll just
rewrite here 25 percent and you're
probably saying where is the decimal in
this well the decimal is after the
number because that 25 percent of the
same thing is 25 point zero percent
right so if we get rid of the percent
sign we move the decimal over two spaces
to the left and that equals 0.25 as a
decimal point two five zero but we can
ignore that last zero so 25 percent
equals 0.25 while 0.25 percent is equal
to point zero zero two five and I want
you to maybe sit and think about how
small of a number point two five percent
is let's do a couple more and maybe we
will convert going the other direction
if I were to say let's say I have the
decimal point zero one and I wanted to
convert that to a percent
well here we just do it the opposite we
could look we could look at it two ways
we could say well whatever number this
is we multiply it by 100 and add a
percent sign so if you say 0.01 times
100 and then we'll add a percent sign
so 0.001 times 100 well that's just 1
right you could do it do the math you
have the percent sign that equals 1
percent or in even easier way when we go
from a percent to a decimal we move the
decimal place over 2 to the left so when
you go from a decimal to a percent we'll
do the opposite we move the decimal two
to the right so if we do that if we let
me just rewrite it Oh point O one if you
just go one to the new decimal place is
here so I mean I could just if I get rid
of that decimal that's zero one decimal
zero zero whatever this obviously this
leading zero means nothing so that's the
same thing as one point zero zero which
is the same thing as one and end does it
make sense that moving the decimal space
two to the right that's really just the
same thing as multiplying it by 100
right if I multiply by something by ten
it's like moving the decimal space one
to the right if I divide something by
ten it's like moving something moving
the decimal space one to the left let's
do a couple more while I have time I
think up three more minutes let's say I
had one point two five and I wanted to
convert to five one point two five want
to convert that to a percent well the
easiest way is just to take I'll rewrite
it here one point two five take the
decimal point and move it two to the
right here so that equals and then I'll
add a percent so that equals one hundred
and twenty five percent and if you think
about it the way people talk about
percent it makes sense if I told you
that I'm going to pay one point two five
times the price of something that makes
sense that that's also I'm going to pay
one hundred and twenty five percent
the price or if it doesn't make sense
hopefully if you if you do these
problems enough it will start to make
sense let's do a couple more and you can
go back and pause this if you think I'm
going too fast which I might be doing
let me do if I were to say let me think
if I were to say point zero zero three
and I want to write this as a percent
well once again we can move the decimal
space to to the right so one two and
that's the analogous to multiplying it
by 100 so if we multiply the decimal two
to the right we get zero zero decimal
point three and then we add the percent
these don't this at least as first
things here doesn't mean anything so
that's the same thing as zero point
three percent so the important thing to
realize is when you when you're
converting from a percent to a decimal
or a decimal to a percent you're really
just moving where that decimal point is
and if if you run out of spaces you just
have to add or get rid of zeros
accordingly and and the important thing
to always have in your mind is when I
convert from a decimal to a percent the
number in front of the percent sign is
going to get bigger and when I go from a
percent sign to a decimal I'm going to
get a smaller number like if I say 25
percent that's the same thing as 0.25
right so this is a percent and this is a
decimal right so I went from a bigger
number 25 to a smaller number point two
five 25% is equal to 0.25
similarly if I'd a decimal let's say
point one when I convert it to a
percentage it's going to be a larger
percentage so 0.1 is the same thing as
10% and how did I do that again well I
said 0.1 I add an extra zero so I'm
gonna have to move the decimal space
over to the right twice so go one two
and I get a ten 10%
hopefully that answers all your
questions for now have fun